PAUL SAXMAN: So Paul Saxman
developer advocate here at
Google and with me is Marcelo,
he's the technical lead on the
Places API.
And we're just going over a
quick demo of the APIs, the
Places APIs that
are available.
There's three big ones and he's
going to start out with
the Places auto complete.
And go into the moderator
queue, go through the
questions in moderator queue,
and then do a few questions
that we hear pretty regularly
about places API or go over a
few questions we
hear regularly.
And then onto the interactive
portion of the show.
I guess it's all interactive.
If anybody has questions along
the way, fire them off and
we'll put them in moderator and
we'll try to get to them.
MARCELO CAMELO: So going
through the demo again.
So I'm starting with
auto complete.
So if you guys are not familiar
auto complete takes
the user input and as the user
is typing the name of a place
it will be suggesting possible
places based on the string
that he typed and also the
view part of the map.
It's pretty similar the auto
complete feature that you have
on maps.google.com.
So here I'll start with a look
at the whole map of the globe.
And I'll just start typing let's
say L so it's suggesting
London, Los Angeles.
If I type B, Berlin,
Barcelona.
So let's pick San Francisco.
So I use the data coming back
from the auto complete widget
and use that to re center
and zoom in into my map.
And I'm getting the view part
back from the map and feeding
back into the auto
complete widget.
So now I'll try again the
same two searches.
So I'll start with an L. Now
it's getting Lombard Street in
San Francisco.
The B, which used to give me
Berlin, Barcelona, is giving
me Berkeley as a first result.
PAUL SAXMAN: So Brazil is in
the top of the list there.
Do you have some connection
with Brazil?
MARCELO CAMELO: Yes,
I'm Brazilian.
So it looks like Google
Maps like
Brazil better than Belgium.
That's good.
So if I now, let's try
getting a Starbucks.
So I type the Star,
I go to Starbucks.
So what I'll do here I'll
add the restriction.
So let's say that I want
only establishment.
So that's local listings, so
business, we'll be getting any
address or countries or anything
like that back.
So if I now type S I get SFO.
So San Francisco, so St
is enough for me to
get Starbucks there.
So we've got a bunch
of Starbucks.
So no matter how hard I try I
will be getting San Francisco
as a result for instance.
I could try instead, let's
say switch to geocodes.
So geocodes will actually
just give me addresses.
Right so if I try getting
Starbucks again.
So I get Starbuck Drive
somewhere in California, but I
don't get Starbucks.
So even the Starbucks Way.
Another restriction I can use
is country restrictions.
So I can type let's say
a country code.
Let's say Australia.
PAUL SAXMAN: I have a
challenge for you.
Can we tell if there's a
Starbucks on Starbucks Way?
MARCELO CAMELO: We could try.
We could go geocode, let me
remove the Australian
restrictions, say
Starbucks Way.
Yeah if we have on
And we'll try establishment.
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh I see.
So you're basically taking
the union of two
searches to get you--
MARCELO CAMELO: I used the
first search to get me to
Starbucks Way and then
I switched it back to
establishment in between the
search for Starbucks.
So there is this--
I forgot where Starbucks Way
is, but yeah so there's a
Starbucks roasting plant
in Starbucks Way.
Which probably the Starbucks
roasting plant is named the
route called Starbucks Way.
So it makes sense that we have
some relationship there.
So yes, so the challenge
accepted.
So going back to
San Francisco.
And I'll put a restriction
of country Australia.
And if I type G so though I'm
looking at San Francisco and
I'm typing G I'm getting the
Gold Coast in Queensland.
If I remove the country
restriction, type G again what
I'll be getting is
Gary Danko, the
restaurant in San Francisco.
So the country restriction
will pretty much overrule
completely the view port bias.
PAUL SAXMAN: So each of these
requests you're passing what
information?
You're passing the type,
potentially a country, the
search query, and then also
the bounding box for your
[INAUDIBLE].
MARCELO CAMELO: And the back end
will mix those up and will
rank all the results.
And bring back the
top five or 10.
PAUL SAXMAN: And this
is all in JSON XML.
[INAUDIBLE] formats.
MARCELO CAMELO: Yeah so
we have a JS API.
That's what I'm using here.
But also if you're writing
something that's not using
JavaScript you can also
use the web service.
And the web service will either
give you responses in
JSON or XML.
So if we go, let's try
going to Sydney.
And then I want to show you a
really recent addition, which
is we called it type
collections.
So auto complete is restricted
in that we can only use the
top two types from type
hierarchy which are
establishment and geocode.
So you cannot specify
say restaurants, or
localities, or suburbs.
So we've added to try to
mitigate that is type
collections.
So for instance, if I type here
look in city and I type
G. I'll be getting first result
city George Street.
But if I instead choose regions
and type G again I'll
be getting Glebe back.
And Glebe is a suburb
of Sydney.
In Australia suburbs
and cities they
have the same meaning.
If I type N instead I'll be
getting New South Wales, which
is the state.
And a bunch of suburbs
and cities mixed in.
But if I use just cities and
type N again I won't be
getting New South Wales now.
Because cities will restrict
it just smaller elements.
A city, a suburb and regions is
more the macro elements on
the geopolitical subdivisions.
So you'll be getting states
and province,
that kind of stuff.
So if you're building something
like let's say a
hotel finder, you may not really
want to give your user
street as results.
You want to give them just
cities and suburbs.
So you'd use the city
type collection.
PAUL SAXMAN: So what would I do
if there was something like
a pseudo establishment?
Like let's say a farmer's
market, so if I want to find
all the farmer's markets.
MARCELO CAMELO: Yeah so you'll
have to be in our indexes.
I don't think we have--
So if it's the farmer market
that is a permanent event we
may have it, but if it's
something that maybe will
happen once a week I don't think
that we will have it in
our indexes.
But that's one interesting
question because what we want
to do with API is we want to
get a sense back from the
development community and their
users of what they think
a place is.
Because currently Google has
it's own idea what a
place should be.
So if you get the feedback from
developers and they have
the ability to add places
using the API.
So if a lot of people start
adding farmer's market or even
bench in a park, there's no
reason if that's recognized by
applications and by users as
a valid and permanent place
there's no reason why it
shouldn't be indexed.
PAUL SAXMAN: So someday we
might see speakeasies in
Google places.
MARCELO CAMELO: So that's it
for the auto complete demo.
And so the other important
service that the place API
provides is the ability
to search for places.
Some people sometimes ask us
where should I use search and
where should I use
auto complete?
So auto complete is really
optimized to an interactive
session with user.
The user is typing something.
He knows what he's
looking for.
He knows the name of the place
he is looking for.
And he's typing into a keyboard
or a soft keyboard on
a mobile device.
And auto complete will spit back
answers really quickly.
So it's really low latency,
really fast, and at the same
time the ability to restrict
your search and refine your
search is much more limited.
So if you're doing more
exploratory type of search, so
you want to know what places are
around a certain suburb or
your user maybe he's holding a
phone right now and want to
know what's the nearest
bar or what's the
nearest grocery shop?
You'd search for that because
the user doesn't know exactly
what he's searching for.
So that's what you would
use search for.
The basic format is you give a
center in the regions and it's
going to return the twenty
places that are most prominent
around the query area,
the search area.
So we're using here in this demo
we're using the map view
port as the search area.
So we can position the map,
let's say around, Moscone
Center and we'll do a search.
So that's all the places API
thinks are the twenty most
prominent places in this
area of San Francisco.
So they are ranked by
order of prominence.
So the most prominent place
are the that come first.
PAUL SAXMAN: And it's really
kind of a variety of different
places right?
MARCELO CAMELO: There's no--
PAUL SAXMAN: Downtown
is a place in here.
MARCELO CAMELO: Yeah, exactly.
I didn't do any restrictions
in terms of what places you
want us to return.
So let me do it again with a
more narrow search radius.
PAUL SAXMAN: And kind of what
I've seen too I mean the
sample of types that you have
here I mean it's really
extensive right?
I mean there's--
MARCELO CAMELO: Yeah, we
have I think around
130 different types.
And there's a lot of important
types that are missing from
the list. But we're trying to
approach it really carefully
because inside Google
those types are
changing all the time.
And once we commit that as an
API to outside developers we
cannot change them anymore.
So we chose to at first expose
just those types that we
really trust aren't changing.
And hopefully we're going to be
bringing more types in the
near future.
So now I can try being
a little bit more
specific with my search.
So I just clicked on store and
now my request will come
mostly for stores.
So you actually can see there's
restaurants that come
back here, flagged as
restaurants in the icon.
But if you actually dig into
them you're going to see
they're maybe a department
store that has a
restaurant or a cafe.
Or MoMA has their own
cafe inside of them.
So the fact that the icon
isn't really for a store
doesn't mean that that place
doesn't match your query.
PAUL SAXMAN: And then one of our
moderator questions was on
how things are ranked in here.
So--
MARCELO CAMELO: All right so, as
I said the basic ranking is
the same one as you get
on Google Maps.
So you're ranking by the
prominence of the place in the
search area.
So you can actually get a place
that is really close to
the search area boundary come
up as the first result.
That probably means it ranks
really high in terms of
popularity and the number of
reviews, that kind of stuff.
But we just recently added an
option to rank by distance.
So when I rank by distance
I'm actually ignoring the
prominence.
And I'm returning them in
order of distance to the
center of the search.
So when I rank by distance I'm
not actually looking at the
boundary anymore.
It's not a search area.
I just give a point.
And then we will return the 20
places that match the query
that are closest
to that center.
PAUL SAXMAN: So then it's
really, I mean the maps window
that you have there won't
drop the pin--
MARCELO CAMELO: If I repeat the
same search you get the
same twenty places no matter
what zoom level I'm at.
So one important point to make
about search by distance.
So as you see here in my little
demo if I untoggle
store, so I have no types
restrictions, I can't actually
search by distance anymore.
If you try doing rank by
distance and you don't provide
a keyword or a type restriction
you get an invalid
request back.
So there's got to be some type
of restriction to your search
because it doesn't really make
sense to make a search when
you say give me the 10 closest
places to this point if you
don't say yeah, but what type of
place are you looking for?
PAUL SAXMAN: Awesome,
so we might want
to dive in to moderator.
Actually I have one
more question.
It was really interesting
to me.
I notice you have check
boxes for the types.
You can specify multiple
types?
MARCELO CAMELO: You
can, absolutely.
Say that I'm working on a
website that is related to
travel so we may want
to do searches.
The user is searching for what
type of attractions are around
a certain location.
So you could do a search
with restaurants,
lodging, museum at once.
And you get all of them.
You don't actually have
to do three searches.
You could do three searches
if you want more
than 20 results though.
So it's up to you how you want
to structure your app.
PAUL SAXMAN: Ultimately I mean
since the developers are
getting this back in just raw
data they can always do their
own intersections.
Their own kind of--
MARCELO CAMELO: Good yeah,
there's always a trade-off
there because we have much
more data, much more
information, in our back end
than the developer has when he
gets the results back.
So we will do a better job at
ranking than what you could do
on the client side.
So just before I go to questions
I just one thing
that I would like to
highlight here.
So if you're searching
for restaurants.
So you get all types of
restaurants and we don't have
types for each different kind
of cuisine for instance.
What you could do is say
restaurants and Italian.
And you're going to get just
restaurants that have some
type of Italian slant in their
maybe menu, or the reviews, or
the description of the place,
or the name of place.
PAUL SAXMAN: You obviously
didn't search in North Beach
because that's kind of
sparse list there.
North Beach is the Italian
neighborhood.
MARCELO CAMELO: Oh right.
So what I could do also could
be say search for karate.
We don't have the specific type
for karate, but I could
do a search and maybe get
some karate schools.
Right so that's the kind of
flexibility that you can get
with searches.
PAUL SAXMAN: Very cool.
Like I said if you have any
questions on these just drop
in moderator.
And we're going to dive in--
Woah every time I reload
moderator the
order's a little different.
So put your questions
in moderator.
We're going to talk about
those right now.
So we have one from
Peter in the UK.
I don't know if Peter's on--
JEREMY: I'm Jeremy.
But I'm with Peter.
He can't-- he's somewhere
else but he can hear us.
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh excellent.
So he had a question on
highlighting KML line segments.
Do you want to just reiterate
that question for us or?
JEREMY: Yeah, sure.
PAUL SAXMAN: We could read it
off moderator for you as well.
JEREMY: Read away.
PAUL SAXMAN: OK cool.
So he's asking is it possible
to highlight a KML line
segment on mouse over?
And the answer to that I think
we determined was, not yet.
But this is actually good one
for our issue trackers, a
feature request. This is one of
these kind of these cases
where we think it's
really nice to
get developer feedback.
Kind of drive where
the product goes.
So under that, so our map has
hundreds of KML lines that
represent roads.
It gets confusing.
We'd like to highlight separate
roads with a color
change or info window pop up.
So this is exactly how we like
to get developer requests.
If you do file one of these
feature requests, always try
to file it with what you're
trying to do and addition to
what you want the API to do.
Because sometimes there's a
little bit of a mismatch.
I mean, we may have another
API coming out
that may fit the need.
In addition to what
you may think the
specific API should do.
So always give us the use case
in addition to what you think
the API itself should
do technically.
JEREMY: OK can I expand on
that question slightly?
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, absolutely.
JEREMY: What we'd like is,
we have this great
mass of roads as KMLs.
When we go over each of these
roads we'd like not only the
road to show up, but some kind
of a pop up just to pop up as
it happens.
Now we're going to pull a lot
information into those pop up
boxes eventually.
We're trying to rewrite that
in AJAX at the moment.
It would be too much to,
as you scanned across,
[INAUDIBLE] be popping up
all the information
to be pouring in.
Initially we just want a little
bit of information.
Just, say, the name the roads
and some very basic
information.
And it should be clear which
road you're looking at when
you go over it.
That's all.
PAUL SAXMAN: Gotcha.
This is great.
Yeah, like I said I don't
personally have the
answer for that one.
But I do understand.
I don't think that's something
that we do support.
What I'll do after the
conversation today is I'll put
the link to our issue
tracker online so
you can link to there.
Everything you just said,
I mean enter as
much information can.
It really helps us to clarify
the use case.
And then once you get in the
issue tracker we can kind of
bounce back and forth
and kind of--
JEREMY: Great, that's
really good.
PAUL SAXMAN: --a
little better.
So yeah so thanks a lot.
And I'll post that soon
after talk today.
We have one more, actually we
have quite a few more, I'm
going to go with what Andreas
back here has
highlighted I guess.
So the question is, since
sometimes the map data API is
deprecated not available anymore
what are the options
to access and synchronize users'
maps, especially from
within the mobile apps?
Marcelo, are you--
MARCELO CAMELO: Yeah, no I'm
not really familiar, super
familiar with maps data API.
PAUL SAXMAN: So maps data API
so this is [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So what he pointed out
was that yeah, it's
not available anymore.
We do have a service called
Fusion Tables.
And I can say that--
I actually went through
this migration myself.
We were working on the
My Tracks app.
We moved from the map data API
over to Fusion Tables.
Fusion Tables is really
straightforward to use it's
just a matter of SQL queries
into a database over HTTP.
So I think it's probably
good option.
Take a look at it.
If you don't think it really
fits what you're looking for
send us a question
and let us know.
One thing somebody just pointing
out Fusion Tables is
experimental, which means that
it's subject to change.
But I would say that it's
a good option over
the maps data API.
So we're actually going to
rattle through a few more
questions kind of quickly here
because we're getting a little
long on time.
So we have one question from
Dave in San Francisco.
So his question was
about the API key.
It looks like he was getting
some errors that the API key
was not valid any longer.
Probably just try a new
API key and let
us know how it goes.
And again if this persists this
could be a platform bug
that you'd want to file against
our issue tracker.
Definitely let us know.
But yeah definitely try
a different API key.
We had one from Norman
Avia and he was
asking about the Places.
How is the order in
Places API shown?
MARCELO CAMELO: So the basic
ranking criteria that we have
is the prominence of the place,
which you could call it
popularity.
Although it's a bit
more complex.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
to go into the details.
Then you have the option to
do the rank by distance.
Which is important
to note here it's
not sorting by distance.
So we don't take the same
results as you would with a
normal ranking and just reorder
them by their distance.
We actually do the search with
a different ranking criteria.
So you actually may get the
results are very different
from searching by what
we call prominence.
Another criteria that can also
come into effect if you're
using the Web Service, you
actually submitting check-ins
is places with a lot of
check-ins will bubble up in
the rankings.
So they'll be on top of the
ranking by prominence.
Unless you're searching by
distance and then check-ins
will be ignored.
PAUL SAXMAN: We got
one question about
the places API events.
The question is whether
there are
public and private settings?
And what is the use case?
Is it appropriate for private
parties or public events?
This is from Leon down
in Melbourne.
Cheers Leon long time no see.
MARCELO CAMELO: So in terms
of private or public.
Events for now, they're only
application specific.
So you'll be adding events and
they'll be showing up on the
results for your specific app.
If they'll be public or private
in terms of it's
John's party or a concert it's
up to you to decide.
You can use it however
you want.
When you add event it won't show
up on other people's app
just on your app.
So it's private in that sense
when it comes to the semantics
that you want to assign to your
events it's up to your
application.
You can use it however
you want.
PAUL SAXMAN: So now onto another
question from Norman.
How long will it take a place
to hit the API after a user
has added via the Android app?
And what other sources are
there to add places?
MARCELO CAMELO: Alright so it
hits your own app immediately.
So you add a place it will
show up in your results
immediately.
Before it hits the Google
canonical index it has to go
through a moderation pipeline.
And we're still trying
to sort that out, how
it's going to work.
Because we have to account for
spanning and also all the
other sources of data
that Google has.
And the second part
of the question
is, what other sources--
PAUL SAXMAN: What other
sources are
there for adding places?
MARCELO CAMELO: So Google has
a lot of ways for anyone to
add a place to Google's
database.
So mapmaker is one.
If you're a business owner you
can add your business in.
Claim it as yours as well.
There's a whole process
for doing that.
And Google uses a bunch of
different feeds and crawling
mechanism to build its index.
Eventually we do want the places
API to be a way for
Google to know about
new places and
changes to existing places.
We just not quite there yet.
It's a difficult problem and
we're trying to tackle it in
the right way.
PAUL SAXMAN: And next up
we have one from Mark.
Is there going to be a
G+ map layer, like
there was with Buzz?
And can I check in
to an event?
And how can I see all events
near a selected place, or
around me on mobile?
So tough question.
MARCELO CAMELO: So G+ map layers
wouldn't be really a
place API in the future
so I can't
really answer that question.
Yes, you can check into event.
And then the third part
of the question is--
PAUL SAXMAN: Whoops
I just lost it.
MARCELO CAMELO: How can
I see all the events
near a selected place?
All right so there's no
way to search for
just for events yet.
So you'll have to do a place
search and then look at all
those places that came
back as a result.
And see the ones that
have event in it.
So there's no way to restrict
results just to those places
that have events yet.
But if you think that's
important for you, you can add
it to the issue tracker and
we're going to look at it.
PAUL SAXMAN: I think we're
getting close to
the end of the queue.
Let's see, we have
one here from--
I'm going to pronounce it wrong,
but [? Minantkey ?].
First question, can I display
the entire world map?
And I should be able to put
everyone's location in my
group in the world map and by
clicking the person I should
initiate a call.
So probably need a little more
clarification on that one.
It sounds a little bit like
a feature request
so we're going to--
MARCELO CAMELO: To me it sounds
more like a description
of an app that he
wants to build.
He wants to display a world
map and show everyone's
location in the map and
click on the person
to initiate a call.
So there's a lot of different
APIs that you're going to have
to use to build an
app like that.
But it sounds like
a cool idea.
PAUL SAXMAN: And I think the
last one we got on here was
from Jeremy in London, where
is the hang out?
JEREMY: [INAUDIBLE]
PAUL SAXMAN: Awesome.
So do we have any questions
from everybody and
anybody logged in?
So Jeremy you're all set?
Peter?
JEREMY: Yeah we're good boys.
PAUL SAXMAN: Awesome.
That's about it for time.
We have a few questions that
we might go over maybe at
another time.
Just about the places API in
general, but I think we
covered pretty much most
everything we had on that
list. So any closing words?
MARCELO CAMELO: Keep submitting
feedback.
JEREMY: Can I just ask, do
you guys have a thing
next week as well.
Is there one next Tuesday?
PAUL SAXMAN: I think we have the
hangouts every week and--
actually we just got
a to be determined.
So I think we've planned them
kind of on a weekly basis.
But we'll post it on Google+.
JEREMY: Cool OK.
PAUL SAXMAN: You can add a
little plus stream and we'll
let you know.
All the connection information
everything will
be posted up there.
JEREMY: Great.
PAUL SAXMAN: And I guess in
terms of being places API or
what not probably be a different
product API next
week so in the maps realm.
That's it for me.
If there's any more
like I said I'll
post the issue tracker.
We'd love to hear the feature
requests you guys have. Any
bugs that you guys
are running into.
Any more questions we'll pick it
up on the Google+ comments
or the hangout.
That's it.
Thanks for tuning in.
MARCELO CAMELO: Thanks guys.